[Música]
[Aplausos]
la peor tragedia de tu vida la peor
tragedia de mi vida o la peor tragedia
de cualquier persona es que no tenemos
si no contamos con estrategias
emocionales para gestionar las
adversidades a las que nos vamos
enfrentando somos equilibristas sin red
de seguridad y entonces en este andar
por la cuerda floja que es la vida
tenemos cosas que llegan a nosotros de
manera inherente
situaciones complejas que nos tiran pero
no nos tiran a una distancia de 20
centímetros nos hacen caer en un
marronazo de 7 metros y este dolor
físico no solo se queda y pasa a la
parte emocional y es donde se empieza a
complicar las cosas para nosotros porque
lo que genera este dolor emocional esta
caída
es que nosotros nos comenzamos a ver
como personas ni cosas ansiosas como
stress resentimiento y la envidia y ahí
no termina sigue empeorando la rueda
porque eso no solo no los quedamos
nosotros sino lo compartimos con los
demás lastimamos a los que están a
nuestro alrededor y como decía santo
tomás de aquino uno no da lo que no
tiene entonces no podemos darles lo que
queremos verdaderamente pero tampoco
podemos recibir aquello que necesitamos
porque estamos imposibilitados porque no
tenemos estos filtros emocionales
y ahí no termina la cosa sigue
empeorando
estamos diseñados para huir de la
amenaza tanto física como emocional
y al huir no tuvimos si nos refugiamos
en el mejor lugar web el mejor sitio nos
refugiamos en situaciones hedónicas
superficiales causas cooperativas de mi
felicidad pero no causas eficientes
entonces subimos al cine
a los vicios a las drogas al desenfreno
a la parte superficial de las cosas y
siguiendo desde la epistemología de
aristóteles
deberíamos quizá en causarnos un poco al
asunto euda y mónica a la parte
sustancial profunda de las cosas
y aquí no termina la historia se empeora
más porque el asunto es que como no
gestionamos nuestras propias emociones
vivimos en este círculo constante y
determinante que nos estropea todo
aquello que hacemos lo que queremos
hacer y lastima demasiado a las personas
que están a nuestro alrededor
para llegar a estas conclusiones salir
de una tragedia al no tener las
herramientas emocionales para llegar un
poquito a esta red de seguridad nací en
el seno de una familia bastante humilde
y con todas las implicaciones que esto
tenía también nací en un lugar de mucha
violencia intrafamiliar alcoholismo
abandono irresponsabilidad situaciones
difíciles que no solo vivo yo sino que
vive en la gran mayoría de los mexicanos
y conforme fue pasando el tiempo tuve la
fortuna de ir haciendo ciertas cositas
que me pudieron dar la posibilidad de ir
incluyendo algunas herramientas
emocionales que pudieran a mí cómo ir
creando esta red de seguridad para que
ante cada golpe pudiera ir más o menos
soportarlos
después me especialicé y me hice una
persona
y descubrí que esto que había intuido
con anterioridad tenía eco y resonancia
no solo con evidencia y protocolos
actuales de la psicología sino con
también evidencia pasada de hace 2000 15
años en la psicología budista y a partir
de eso decidí hacer una investigación a
la cual denominó el modelo rhea un
modelo un primer modelo de resiliencia
para crear una primera red ante estas
adversidades emocionales es lo que les
vengo a compartir aquí
él
el primer punto o el primer pilar que
sustenta que le da sostén a este modelo
rey es el de abrirlos
y este lo tomé de una monja alemana que
se hizo budista y en uno de sus libros
menciona cuando todo se derrumba hay que
dar espacio al no saber
porque la historia así como comienza
como así como comienza no termina
y normalmente nosotros cuando viene el
dolor emocional
salimos corriendo y la idea y la
propuesta de esta monja es detenerse
refrenarse esperar a que va en que va a
acabar la historia normalmente estamos
como condicionados a buscar ciertas
circunstancias para nuestro bienestar y
tener éxito lograr ciertas cosas cumplir
con ciertas expectativas mías y de la
sociedad pero no sabemos en qué va a
acabar esa historia y la determinamos si
tengo un buen trabajo me va a ir bien si
me sacó la lotería me va a ir más que
bien
pero tengo dos ejemplos aquí bien
bonitos que reflejan que es bien
importante detenerse y regenerarse antes
de determinar proyectarnos en esta
historia a una persona que conocí le
robaron el coche
y al robar el coche sufrió demasiado
porque le costó muchísimo trabajo
detenerlo
tres días después él estaba en la agonía
no en el dólar en el dolor total
descubrió que este coche estaba chocado
en la carretera y las personas habían
muerto
el coche estaba estaba mal entonces
evidentemente qué bueno que se lo
robaron no se accidentó de él y la
reclusión en el coche y todo perfecto
eso es lo que parecía una cosa trágica
terminó siendo el mejor algo favorable y
viceversa personas que conozco que
tienen empleos excepcionales los
primeros días viven felices pero después
viven del tormento porque les quita
tiempo les quita vida les quita espacio
entonces en lugar de ser felices están
mal pues la idea de este primer pilar es
podernos refrenar ante la circunstancia
emocional antes de determinar si esto es
bueno o malo respirar darse este punto
de apertura el segundo punto lo tome de
una persona excepcional que ha sido mi
maestro mi amigo y mi mentor valentín
méndez un hombre excepcional
que tiene una preparación tanto en
psicología budista como en psicología
que tiene que con mindfulness y él en
uno de sus cursos comentó la siguiente
frase el loto puedo extraer de stefan
entendiendo así que el loto es la única
flor que nace del fango y lo que él
propone y que yo estoy tratando de
modelar para darle sostén a esto
desde cada experiencia compleja difícil
que me llega que puedo exponer qué
sabiduría puedo tener está entonces si
juntamos estos dos pilares vamos
construyendo como una primera red
ante la emoción difícil me refiero flows
y después analiza qué puedo extraer de
esto y muchas personas podrían decir que
para extraer de una infidelidad de un
engaño de que me robaron que
precisamente en eso uno puede generar
una aspiración de no replicar ese
comportamiento por ejemplo se me ocurre
eso no y al extraer esto la densidad del
dolor disminuye en nosotros y nos
empieza a generar un estado como de paz
de tranquilidad
y no de sufrimiento iracundo o sin
sentido el dolor por supuesto natural
existe pero no el sufrimiento exagerado
por el cual tendremos mucho ahí hemos el
tercer punto que me parece el más
importante de todo esto es la idea de
reconectarse vivimos aislados vivimos
como diría el dalai lama en un egoísmo
estúpido y no en un egoísmo inteligente
normalmente pensamos sobre nosotros y yo
y mi bienestar en mis objetivos en mi
casa en mi coche mi dinero en mi éxito y
mi reconocimiento pero se nos olvida que
no somos seres independientes somos
seres interdependientes que la felicidad
completa no está en mí sino en que los
otros también la tengan en las causas
que género yo para que el otro también
lo esté
tengo un tío que el cirujano
y que por alguna extraña razón decidió
vivir en esta palabra no una de las
entidades más difíciles de la ciudad de
mexico
y pues una casa enorme y sus coches y
todo y yo lo podía creer y en cualquier
momento lo va a notar lo van a saltar lo
van a secuestrar le va a pasar algo y al
contrario decidió hacer más o menos esto
que propone el doctor alan wallace que
es la interconectividad con el otro
empezó a inmiscuirse con la colonia y
entonces la sorprendente ver como él
llegara el doctor de renombre la gente
lo saludaba le pedía consultas estaba a
su lado y hamás en como los 20 años que
habrá vivido ahí tuvo un solo rayo en su
casa un solo intento de asalto nada y
eso se nos olvida mucho nosotros
entonces la idea de esta parte del
reconectarse no sólo es ver por el otro
y que también tiene necesidad de sufre
diques es importante que uno conecte con
eso sino desarrollar también en nosotros
este sentido de autocompasión de bondad
de morosidad no porque estemos en la
cuarta transformación no por supuesto no
pero pero sí es muy necesario porque
pregúntense porque el mundo está en éste
cochambre que vive
porque estamos así porque solo vemos por
nuestros propios intereses no tenemos
desarrollada esta capacidad de empatía y
cuando queremos hacerla se vuelve como
como sutil como
endeble porque es como ficticia es
artificial porque no lo hemos cultivado
entonces a partir de estos tres pilares
que les vengo presentando espero que
puedan ayudarles un poquito a entender
que es bien importante el tener una red
de seguridad emocional
para no caernos para hacer empezar a
hacer recipientes emocionales
resistentes y como dice inquebrantables
muchas gracias